let's talk about wild cards okay and
wild cards are somebody we least expect
okay
uh
there were talks of a
rock saying hey one day
you know he wouldn't mind becoming the
president you hear logan paul and jake
paul talk about they're going to be
presidents logan paul to me i think that
guy's got a big upside he's he's
entertaining he's smart he's good
looking he's a good talker
he's a great marketer he's a good
storyteller but he's young right but in
a
setting where a dwayne johnson the rock
my opinion this is a perfect time for
him to run if he wants to win now
politically would you agree with him
this is not about politics i'm not
asking policies i'm asking timing-wise
the left doesn't have an exciting
candidate okay the right
is confused between two different
candidates if there's ever been a time
for a guy like to jump in there whether
you like his policies or not it's
irrelevant do you think this would be a
good time for the rock to make a move uh
it's a tremendous advantage uh in
american politics particularly
presidential panics to begin
well known
ronald reagan had a career before
politics donald trump had a career
before politics so they were both able
in a way to skip the step the first step
of politics which has become well known
candidates like the rock begin well
known i'm not sure which party he's in
i'm not really clear what his politics
are
uh but it is not inconceivable that he
could be a viable candidate because he
has that elusive quality he's got
celebrity quality he's extremely well
known that's an excellent leg up it's
one of the principal reasons why trump
was able to be nominated so so if we do
match-ups we do match-ups you know how
you
see the boxing match up 74-inch rage
versus 72 and a half height weight 178
what's okay let's zoom at the tail of
the table exactly right so
so you got the rock versus reagan reagan
was a b
level actor he wasn't an a he but he'd
been governor and and he had a very
significant okay so that's governor
perfect so fair enough so that's the age
so the rock somebody could say
highest paid actor right he's made his
money
uh he's got god knows how many followers
on social media he's an international
figure so he's got that part
um then if you look at some of the other
names if you compare him to trump well
trump wins on success of business you
know what he's built his brand but the
rock may win for you know being more
famous
policies
trump's been talking policies since the
80s i don't know if the rock's been
talking politics for 30 years so that's
the one part where he has even he
himself said this is not an area where i
excel in but all i'm asking is in a
situation like this
if you got a call from one of these guys
from one of their handlers saying hey we
want this thing to be
you know we want you to sign an nda and
we don't want you to say this to anybody
we are willing to hire you as a you know
political
uh strategist but no one knows this
if feedback was given to them what would
you say to some of these guys you want
to be president run for governor you
want to be president run for senator in
other words trump would run on a
four-year record of unprecedented
economic growth rebuilt of our building
of our military appointments scores of
conservatives to the court he's got a
record to run on i don't think you can
go from actor to president without an
intermediate step reagan had two terms
as governor of california very
successful terms that's what qualified
him to be president his his his uh
presence obviously his charisma made him
a strong candidate but it was the record
that mattered crazy question for you if
arnold was born in the u.s could he have
been a president he may have been of
course his politics shifted over time
right so he started as a reagan
republican he ended up as a kennedy
democrat
right right that's not too far removed
though these days these days yeah that's
true they went from 40 yard line to 40
yard line that's the way i would is is
there anybody else you see there that's
a wild card that has a shot at uh you
know shaking things up in 2024. i i
don't see it okay
it's two years from now it's very hard
to say two years is a long time of
politics it is really a month is a long
time okay so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]